zappez challenge people flyers mail
basket
on entend parfois dire que le français
emprunterait des mots en anglais on
appelle ça des anglicismes pour s'en
protéger on a même créé une loi la loi
toubon en 1994 qu'il est en fait tous
les mots à consonance anglaise ne
proviennent pas forcément de la langue
de shakespeare pour le prouver on a
choisi six mots et on a demandé aux
journalistes qui thérère du figaro ces
plans étaient challenge vient en réalité
de l'ancien français challenges issu du
latin kaloum yari accusé faussement le
mot est apparu dans notre dictionnaire
français au xième siècle sous la forme
de chalonge pour désigner la provocation
par extension le terme a pris une
nouvelle signification au 12e siècle
le défi c'est n'est finalement qu'au 14e
siècle les anglais nous empruntons le
mot le mot mail malgré sa prononciation
vient de l'ancien français mal au 12e
siècle
il désignait un sac ou un coffre qu'on
emporte avec soi lorsqu'on partait en
voyage
il a par la suite désigné une valise
dans laquelle on transportait les
lettres comme toux maux il a évolué avec
son temps et il a fini par changer de
définition c'est à partir du xviiie
siècle que la malle a fini par désigner
les lettres et les colis qu'elle
contenait
quand on lance j'ai zappé quelque chose
on veut dire j'ai oublié quelque chose
on zappe aussi devant la télévision pour
passer de chaîne en chaîne
mais en anglais le verbe se zaps emploi
dans un tout autre registre il serait
dérivé de l'onomatopée zap qui signifie
un bruit d'armes
il signifie donc tu es éliminé ou
annulés dans le dictionnaire de
l'académie française la basket désigne
une chaussure de sport en cuir ou en
toile
quoi qu'il en soit le mot basket n'a pas
le même sens en anglais le mot basket en
anglais lui désigne un panier on parlera
de sneaker ou de trainose en anglais
pour désigner la fameuse basket
à l'origine people vient du latin
populis peuple au xiiie siècle le
français adoptent le mot sous la forme
de pot bleu people en anglais désigne
l'exact contraire du people en français
que l'on utilise pour parler d'une
célébrité depuis les années 80 people en
anglais désigne littéralement n'importe
qui une personne ou un groupe de
personnes le mot flyers vient de
l'anglais to fly qui veut dire voler
mais en bon français cette feuille
volante se dit prospectus alors pourquoi
ne pas l'utiliser